- Hi, I'm Brendan Hunt,
and I'm gonna try and
(whip cracks)
finish the Ted Lasso quote.
I'm going up against my fellow castmates,
Hannah Waddingham.
- Come on boys, bring it on.
- [Brendan] And Cristo Fernández.
- Let the battle begin.
- I intend to crush them.
- Right, Rebecca,
(whip cracks)
do you believe in ghosts?
I do, but more importantly, I believe...
- I believe they
believe in themselves.
(bell dings)
- No, that's wrong.
It should be, I think they
should believe in themselves.
(bell dings)
- Do you live in ghosts?
I do, but more importantly,
I believe they need to
believe in themselves.
(bell dings)
- Do I get a point?
- [Crew] I'll give you
it, you get that point,
you got that point.
- Thank you.
(whip cracks)
I think you might
be so sure that you're one in a million
that sometimes you forget
that out there, you're just...
Oh God, who says that?
- Um. (laughs)
Um.
- Ah, that's to Jamie Tartt, isn't it?
Isn't that Ted to Jamie Tartt?
You're just...
- Unique? (laughs)
(buzzer buzzes)
It's not, but I don't know.
- I think you might be so sure
that you're one in a million
that sometimes you forget that out there,
you're just one of 11.
(bell dings)
- One of 11?
Yes!
Working it though.
- One of 11?
Oh yes, of course, ah!
(whip cracks)
- You know what
the happiest animal on Earth is?
It's a goldfish.
- A goldfish.
- Goldfish.
You know why? It's got a ten
second memory. (bell dings)
- Because it has a
ten second memory.
(bell dings)
- Because they have a two second memory.
(buzzer buzzes)
10 second memory!
- [Crew] It's still counted,
- Thank you!
- [Crew] We'll still count it.
(whip cracks)
- This woman right here
is strong, confident and powerful.
Boss, I tell ya, I'd hate to see you and,
oh, I don't know.
(buzzer buzzes)
- Michelle Obama arm wrestle.
(bell dings)
- Michelle Obama in an arm wrestle.
I'd like to see her
in an arm wrestle, 'cause I just want to
fan-girl all over the place.
- Michelle Obama, oh my God, yeah, okay.
No, I got it very wrong.
Hannah has the best, beautiful arms ever.
(whip cracks)
Blank is the best.
It's kinda like seeing Billy Joel live.
Never disappoints.
Um.
- Oh.
Oh.
- Ice cream?
(bell dings)
Boom.
- What is the best?
Um, Danny?
(buzzer buzzes)
- Oh God, I wanted a clean run.
In my head, all that's
going on is biscuits.
(buzzer buzzes)
- Ice cream, oh my God.
- (laughs) Oh, that's so annoying.
(whip cracks)
- Taking on a challenge
is a lot like
riding a horse, isn't it?
(bell dings)
If you're comfortable
while you're doing it,
you're probably doing it wrong.
- Riding a horse!
(bell dings)
- Sexy time?
(buzzer buzzes)
(Hannah chuckles)
Riding a horse?
Well, similar.
(whip cracks)
- I do love a locker room.
It smells like testicles.
(buzzer buzzes)
No, potential.
(bell dings)
- Potential.
- Smells like potential.
(bell dings)
It's a good line.
(whip cracks)
- As a man once said,
the harder you work,
the luckier you get.
(bell dings)
- I know this isn't right,
the sweatier you get?
(buzzer buzzes)
- The better you get?
Better?
(buzzer buzzes)
No.
- The luckier, I think
my one's better. (laughs)
- Ah, okay.
- Your body is like blank.
If it ain't warmed up properly,
something real bad could happen.
Uh...
- I was just trying to think
like Jason, or like Brendan.
- Nitroglycerin?
No. (buzzer buzzes)
Uh, rice.
(bell dings)
Uncooked rice.
(buzzer buzzes)
Raw rice?
- Um...
- Raw?
(buzzer buzzes)
Uncooked?(buzzer buzzes)
Rice? (bell dings)
- Rice, I don't know.
(bell dings)
What is it?
- Day-old rice.
(bell dings)
Day-old rice!
Boom.
- Day-old rice?
(bell dings)
Yes!
- Yes, of course.
- The end!
(whip cracks)
Did I only screw up one?
(buzzer buzzes)
(whip cracks)
- Hopefully I'll do
better next time. (laughs)
(whip cracks)
- 100%, Hannah.
100%, Cristo.
Where are ya?
- I knew it!
(Crew speaks indistinctly)
But he's a writer.
- Yeah, who write this?
- I got a perfect though,
I think that's the main thing to remember.
(upbeat music)
- I'm so competitive. (laughs)